bonsoir bonsoir merci ça fait plaisir
que vous comprenez ici parce que comme
je suis un rappeur parfois les gens
quand elles voient ils confondent avec
le feu là je vais pas rappeler là je
voulais parler du racisme anti blanc
parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'endroits où le
ou les blancs sont sont pas bien en
valeur par exemple moi je fais des
concerts en prison et là bas quand tu
vois les prisonniers les blancs sont
vachement se représentait en fait s'il
peut être pas tous dans les prisons je
veux dit c'est du gâchis vu le potentiel
que vous avez avec tous vos pédophiles
il ya un autre endroit où il ya du
racisme anti blanc selon moi c'est
l'équipe de france de foot ce qu'il y a
que des noirs sur le terrain après pour
compenser toutes leurs compagnes sont
blanches donc savoir le racisme anti
blanc c'est quentin sutton insultes ta
culture on insulte pas couleurs de poser
comme comme la vie des droits en france
notre soirée lyon
[Applaudissements]